on a eu envie de vous présenter un film
qui était une véritable célébration du
cinéma ce film c'est millenium actress
film d'animation japonais réalisé par
satoshi kon en 2001
millénium actrice cette actrice
millénaire c'est sciglio qu au fuji
houara inquiète une actrice de fiction
une actrice de l'âge d'or des studios
japonais et cette actrice personnage
principal du film est retirée isolé dans
sa maison depuis près de 30 ans elle va
accepter la visite et la demande
d'interview d'un journaliste qui
accompagné de son de son caméraman va
assister au récit de la vie en même
temps que le spectateur de la vie de
cette actrice
le film est une plongée vertigineuse et
époustouflant visuellement dans
l'histoire du cinéma et du cinéma
japonais
la vie de cette actrice se mêle à tous
les rôles qu'elle a interprété dans tous
ses films le réalisateur satoshi kon
brouille la frontière entre fiction et
réalité c'est vraiment une oeuvre qui
méritent d'être découvertes ou
redécouvertes connu et reconnu